Visual intelligence is the concept that
we see more than we can process and it's
the idea of thinking about what we see
taking in the information and what do we
really need to live our lives more
purposefully and do our jobs more
effectively.
What I asked the people in the art of
perception to do,
one of them is looking down at a piece
of paper and the other one is looking at
the painting and then they have one
minute to describe what it is that they
see to their partner and the partner has
to sketch what they hear and it's not
about the artwork.
It's not about how well you draw.
It's how well can you describe a new set
of unfamiliar data?
How well do you listen and how well do
you take that articulation and transfer
it to your own language?
Yeah.
How many of you said there was a train
coming out of a fireplace and everyone
raises his or her hands and how many of
you referenced smoke or steam in your
discussion?
Lots of hands go up and then I asked the
question,
who mentioned who articulated that?
There are no tracks under the trade and
a few astute people actually raised
their hand and said,
no.
I said there were no tracks under the
train,
and then I asked who noticed and then
articulated that there was no fire in
the fireplace and hands go up,
not too many.
And then we talk about other aspects of
the painting.
How many people mentioned the woodgrain
on the floor.
Most people notice the wood grain on the
floor.
How many people mentioned wainscoting,
that kind of paneling on the walls,
and I always have some decorative arts
aficionados.
Oh yes.
I know about wainscoting and then I say,
how many of you mentioned a mantle on
the fireplace?
Lots of hands go up.
Who mentioned candlesticks.
And then I asked,
how many of you said there were no
candles in the candlesticks?
And people say,
Oh nope.
Never got there.
And then I ask,
okay,
what really observant nerd said it's
1242 or eight.
Oh,
five on the clock.
Who got to mention the time?
And the reason I asked I have that line
of questioning is because this painting
illustrates a really very important
concept that I transferred from
emergency medicine to a much broader
application and the idea is called the
pertinent negative.
It's saying what isn't there in addition
to what is there to actually give a more
accurate picture of what you're looking
at.
So when you say I see a train coming out
of a fireplace,
and by the way there are no tracks under
the train and there is no fire in the.
Why would you attempt to say what's not
there?
Because in my third grade mind,
if you told me to draw a fireplace,
I would draw two sticks and a fire and
smoke in the fireplace unless you told
me not to.
And if you told me to draw a pair of
candlesticks,
I'll draw candles with flames unless you
tell me not to.
So the pertinent negative is this
wonderful concept that gives us a
broader way of looking at something.
Instead of looking at something like
this,
you look at it like this.
And here's the example,
an example of how you apply that in the
real world.
The pertinent negative in a medical
situation is when someone comes into the
emergency room and they have all the
symptoms,
it appears to the physician,
they have all the symptoms of pneumonia.
Pneumonia has three symptoms,
symptom one is present symptom to is
present,
but if symptom three is absent,
it's the pertinent negative.
You have to say symptom three is not
there,
therefore it's not pneumonia.
So in the real world,
outside of medicine,
how can we use this?
If we have an expectation of someone,
someone's behavior,
you expect them to behave a certain way
and then they don't.
You need to say it didn't happen.
You're evaluating someone on the job.
Well,
you did A,
B and c very well,
but you didn't do the e and f.
So it's looking at the affirmative and
looking at the negative and the
pertinent negative is a wonderful tool
missing missing persons cases.
You go to their homes,
what's not there?
The cell phone's not there.
The keys are not there.
The wallet is not there.
You're going to have a very different
search for that person if those things
were present instead of absent.
So this mughal painting gives us this
great opportunity to talk about not just
what we see,
but what we don't see to give the person
who can't see what we see a much more
accurate description of what they're
looking at.